- Good evening, I'm Priya Natarajan.
I happen to be the current director
of the Franke Program in
Science and Humanities.
I'm delighted to see you all here
for the Franke Distinguished
Speaker Series,
in which we have featured leading thinkers
whose work and intellectual influence
transcends traditional
disciplinary boundaries.
First I would like to
thank our generous donors,
Mr. and Mrs. Richard
Franke, Richard and Barbara,
who are here in the audience.
Thank you so much for not
just endowing this series,
but also being here with us
and participating actively
in the activities that
we've been organizing.
So, second, after the
talk I want to mention
we have a very nice reception
downstairs in room 108,
and I wanted to remind you
that we would really like
to invite you to continue
the conversation there,
and there's a really nice
food, as well as alcohol.
Okay, and then I'm required
to give you this notice
before I get on to today's program
that the event is actually
being recorded and photographed
for educational archival
and promotional purposes,
including use in print or the internet
and other forms of media.
By attending this event today
you agree to the possibility
of your voice or perhaps your likeness
captured by these means and
used only for such purposes
without compensation
to you and hereby waive
any related right of privacy or publicity.
Now that I'm done with
the recording formalities,
this brings us to our
speaker this evening,
Professor Gary Tomlinson, who is
a true transdisciplinary and scholar.
He serves as the current director
of the Whitney Humanities Center at Yale,
and Tomlinson is a musicologist
with a long commitment
to multidisciplinary
exploration and his teaching,
lecturing, and scholarships
span and reflect
this broad intellectual diversity.
Central among the the various
strong research interests
of his have been the traditions
of European classical music,
including the history of opera
and early modern musical
thought and practice,
but his work has always
opened up to broader visions
and perspectives the social context
in which music making happens
and he has produced many
wonderful essays and books
on music of the indigenous
American societies,
jazz, cultural and anthropological theory,
and the philosophy of history.
His recent book is titled
"Culture and the Course
of Human Evolution"
and I think in this book, he offers
a very intriguing and
compelling expanded view
of our human origin story.
So this latest project is part of work
that he has been doing over
the past couple of years
intersecting with archeology
and evolutionary biology,
looking at the role of musical capacities
in the emergence of modern humanity.
He has several other books, which include,
maybe I'll list a couple,
it's a long list, include
"Monteverde and the End
of the Renaissance,"
"Music in the Renaissance
Magic," and and so on.
He's also looked at
indigenous voice in the era
of European contact and music
and historical critique.
He is also, many of you, like I did,
might have known of
him, well I knew of him
well before I met him,
because of his music
appreciation book, text book,
called "Listen," which I encountered
when I was an undergraduate at MIT.
It's now in its seventh edition.
So Tomlinson was awarded a
BA from Dartmouth College
and a PhD from the University
of California at Berkeley.
He arrived at Yale in
2010 after several years
as the distinguished Annenberg
Professor in the Humanities
at UPenn; he served as a Phi
Beta Kappa visiting scholar
and has had many many prizes from the
American Musicological
Society, the British Academy.
He's a member of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences
and recipient of Guggenheim
and the MacArthur Fellowships,
so, it goes on and on, but
without much further ado,
because I am very impatient
to hear what he has to say,
his talk today is titled
"The Third Algorithm:
"The Evolution of Human Culture."
Gary, it's a real
privilege to have you here.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you, thank you all for being here,
I truly thank you all for being here.
It's a moist day and and many
of you were eager to go home
and find out what a complete
exoneration looks like
up close and personal,
(audience laughing)
and I want to thank Priya
for the invitation to to
speak under the auspices
of the wonderful Franke Program
in Science and Humanities
and of course I too, I
never tire of thanking
Rich and Barbara for all of
their extraordinary support,
and over the years, not
only for this program,
but for many other programs at the Whitney
and many other programs
at Yale in general.
So, "The Third Algorithm."
This is, as Priya has already
said, I somewhat immodestly
put up covers of a couple of recent books.
This is an extension of the talk today.
It is an extension of
these recent studies.
The first of them, "A
Million Years of Music,"
was an attempt to understand
how it is that humans came,
what the evolutionary
dynamic was by which humans
came to be, music and creatures.
There was a model of
cultural evolutionary dynamic
that was mooted there that
I wanted to explore more
and that's what happened in
"Culture and the Course
of Human Evolution,"
and it is never, there's
no bottom to this question,
I go on exploring it, and
some further exploration
is what I will be talking about today.
The algorithm referred to in my title,
I will get to the third,
I have to get to the first
and second first, however.
The algorithm in my title,
what I mean by an algorithm
in this case is indeed
a set of conditions.
I don't quite mean the
Google and Amazon things
that are controlling all our lives,
but rather a set of conditions
that set processes in motion, basically,
and the first and foremost algorithm
in evolutionary thinking, as you all know,
is Darwin's natural selection.
Here's the algorithm.
If you have a group of organisms,
a population of organisms,
that passes along traits
to successive generations,
that is to say there is inheritance,
and you have, in that that inheritance,
there is some variation of those traits
from generation to generation,
and all of this is happening
in a landscape of not unlimited resources,
there will be selection.
The process is set in motion
by those conditions alone.
I'm not going to read quotations
from a lot of my slides
today, but I do want to read
these wonderful words from
the beginning of chapter four
in "On the Origin of Species."
"Can it be thought
improbable that variations
"useful in some way to each being
"in the great and complex battle of life
"should sometimes occur in the course
"of thousands of generations?
"If such do occur, can we doubt,
remembering that many more
"individuals are born
than can possibly survive,
"that individuals having any
advantage, however slight,
"over others would have the best chance
"of surviving and procreating their kind.
"On the other hand, we may feel sure
"that any variation in
the least degree injurious
"would be rigidly destroyed.
"This preservation of
favorable variations,
"and the rejection of injurious variations
"I call natural selection."
Now, Darwin in his model
of natural selection
builds the question of resources into it.
You can see that in this quotation,
in the reference to the
many more individuals
that are born than can possibly survive
or the complex battle of life,
and indeed his model
for for thinking about
population dynamics in the first place,
was Malthus's model, Thomas
Malthus from around 1800.
The Malthusian model, as
most of you most of you
are familiar with, is absolutely bound up
with the waxing and waning of resources.
But this, when we take seriously
this question of resources,
we need to move beyond natural selection
to a second algorithm, a second algorithm
that has always been present.
We can see it implicitly
in in Darwin's model,
has always been present
in evolutionary thinking
since Darwin, but has in
recent decades burgeoned
into primary importance in
in evolutionary thinking.
And this second algorithm
is the algorithm of niche construction.
Niche construction, this
now is is a feedback loop,
a feedback cycle between the
environment and the organisms.
The top of the feedback cycle here
is essentially Darwin's natural selection.
The environment exerts, as
the metaphor usually has it,
exerts a selective pressure
on organisms living in it.
Some variants of those, or some variants
are selected for, other
variants are selected against
because of the nature of the
affordances and constraints
that the environment offers.
The other side of this
feedback loop, however,
is what niche construction
wants to focus on,
and that is the fact that organisms
change their environments
in living in them,
that there are no organisms
anywhere in the history of life,
here or anywhere else,
wherever life may be,
that could possibly be so light-footed
that they would have no impact whatsoever
on their environments.
If they do have impacts
on their environments,
however, we need to take account of that
in our model of natural selection,
because the selective
gradient, the selective terrain
of the environment is not
only changing the genomes
of these of these organisms
through many many generations
but the organisms in their behaviors,
in their life ways, are
changing the environment.
So the environment is changing
the organisms and vice versa.
Now if we were to leap ahead to talk
about cultural organisms,
cultural animals, that is,
animals that that have cultural behaviors,
we would immediately understand
that in order to think
about niche construction
of cultural animals,
we're gonna have to think
about the role of culture
in changing the environment, right?
Culture is, and the cultures of animals
are not simply neutral, they are part
of their niche construction,
so the question
of how these cultures
change their their niches,
change the nature of the construction,
is one that we will have to
build into our feedback cycle
of niche construction.
Now I've gotten ahead of myself,
because I haven't yet said
what I think of what a culture might be.
Here's a definition of culture from,
that evolutionists have taken
up for about the last 30 years
or so in trying to understand
the dynamics of culture
as it plays a part in
evolutionary process.
There it is, Pete Richerson
and Robert Boyd,
"information learned and
transmitted from one generation
"to another through teaching
imitation and similar means."
The crucial elements of this
are the learning of information,
the transmitting of information
through some sort of imitative
or pedagogical means.
Now this is a hugely
broad view of culture.
It's a view of culture that
is certainly broad enough
to open out our notion of cultural animals
well beyond Homo sapiens
in the world today.
We can think of songbird cultures.
We can think of humpback whale cultures.
We can think of sperm
whale cultures, by the way,
then the this is only
recently really made clear,
but the click codes by
which, that are learned
and transmitted from
generation to generation
are rather complex codes by which whales
not only identify their pods,
but they also identify
individuals within their pods.
Whale cultures, in other
words, we can think of,
of course, a number of a
number of non-human primates
in the world today that have cultures
according to this broad definition,
chimpanzees, bonobos, maybe gorillas,
some other monkeys, even,
beyond beyond the great apes.
So this a broad view of
culture is the first point.
The second point before
I move on from this
is that we need to think
a little bit more broadly
about the information
that is at stake here.
We can think first that
there is a particular kind
of information that I want to get to
and that is the information
that is embodied in culture,
the information that is learned
and transmitted in culture.
It plays a role and it is an outgrowth
of a much much broader
kind of information,
a much more broader
informational foundation.
This broad informational foundation is,
we can think of as
operative correspondences
that are evolved into living things.
Think of the relationship
between, the correspondences
between, a messenger RNA
molecule and a DNA molecule,
or the correspondences between
a messenger RNA molecule
with its codons and the
amino acids that bond
to those codons making up
polypeptides, proteins finally.
These are these are all
informational processes
in any useful definition of information
that has come along since the 1940s,
these would be considered
informational processes.
But the information and
culture is of a different sort.
The information and culture
is is information about.
It is information about the niche.
It is information about
the sociality of animals
on the niche; it is the information
about how it is that they move forward
in constructing their niche.
The question then comes to be,
how did this difference in
kinds of information come along?
How did aboutness arise?
And that takes us to the third algorithm.
The third algorithm is
sign-making, or semiosis.
Semiosis is a special animal
interaction with the world,
and it creates a very distinctive kind
of information processing
in its complexity.
And I've laid out a little chart here
that gives you a starting point,
as I see it, for semiosis.
Again this is the view
of semiosis not as doubt
that is going to be, like
culture, is going to be
broadly dispersed across
many many animals.
Many more animals, in fact, are semiotic
than finally are cultural
animals in this view.
Where do we start?
We start with the notion
of an attentive animal,
the notion of an animal that
can pay attention to things.
This is not true of all animals.
It's certainly not true
of plants, microbes,
and other, and molecules themselves,
but the notion of attention is,
has been much researched recently
by people from many many different fields.
They take in the notion
of top-down processing
from complex central nervous functions,
such as memory, learning,
even rudimentary memory
and rudimentary learning,
they take into account also
the filtering of the
sensory stimuli that come
to the animal from the outside world.
They take all of those
things into account,
but what all of these views of semiosis,
all of these views of attention agree on,
whatever their other differences,
is that attention is first
of all a capacity to winnow
or to focus or to, well,
to focus on certain stimuli
from among all of those
stimuli that are impinging
on the animal at any at any given moment.
This notion of a winnowing
or a focusing is something
that then enables animals
to bring into salience
certain stimuli, while not
attending is quite so much
to other stimuli, right?
And not only that, because
it brings them into salience,
in conjunction with these
top-down neural systems,
it enables the easier
memorization of them.
It enables learning about the stimuli.
It enables many things.
But one thing is, there's one thing
that these attention researchers
don't quite pick out,
pick out as often as I think they might,
and that is the recursive
quality to attention.
If you have an animal
that is able to winnow
from among all the
stimuli impinging on it,
just a set of stimuli and
pay attention to those,
well we can recursively
see that that animal,
given whatever the limit, within
the limits of its sensorium
and and its cognitive patterns,
that animal might be
able to winnow further
and pay attention to a fewer,
a smaller number of stimuli
within the group of stimuli
that it might otherwise
have paid attention to.
This opens up something that
is to me immensely important.
It opens up the possibility of
attending not only to things,
as in their wholes, but
attending to aspects or qualities
or traits of things in
very particular ways,
and this opens up the possibility, then,
of a part for whole association
whereby an animal could
focus, could attend
to one aspect of something and
that aspect of the something,
of whatever it was, could
refer to the whole something,
even though it was a single aspect of it.
What I'm describing here is
of course a rudimentary sign.
It is semiosis in action.
What comes about at this
moment is that the quality
or the aspect of the
broader set of stimuli
that is being focused on can come to refer
to that broader set, it can
come to mean that broader set.
It can come to be about that broader set.
Here's an instance, here's
our European robin back again.
This is a very intelligent animal,
able to attend in all
kinds of complex ways
to the world around it.
It has been fed during its childhood
by, say, regurgitated
food from its parents
but it has also attended to the fact
that its parents eat red berries.
It has attended to this, but
by this recursive principle
that I've been talking about,
it can also attend to
qualities of those berries,
individual qualities, it
doesn't have to take on
every aspect of the berries to know
that those berries might
be something it might eat.
It doesn't have to take on the
relationship of the berries
to the leaves or the
branches on which they grow.
It doesn't have to take on many things,
but it might take on just
a single quality of them.
Say, the redness of the berries, right?
Once it does that, once it makes
a part for whole association
between the redness
and the berries as a whole, it has created
a simple sign of the berry,
a sign of what it eats,
redness then can connote, can mean,
can refer to, what it eats.
A sign and its object.
Now, this is a very simple kind of sign.
It is, in fact, what
Charles Sanders Peirce
famously called an icon.
It is the simplest kind
of sign, but it is one,
it is a simple sign, a foundation
from which a hierarchy of
more and more complex signs
will be built.
So here's another instance of an icon.
An icon then for Peirce, for me as well,
for Terrence Deacon, who is
referred to in this slide,
who was a neo-Peircian of the first order,
who has done all kinds of
analysis of Peircian semiosis,
an icon is a sign that there's
a qualitative resemblance
to its object.
In this case, we have a
painting of a woolly mammoth
on a cave wall, it's Pech
Merle in southern France.
This refers to the woolly mammoth
itself, to the real thing.
It refers to the real thing by virtue
of only certain aspects
of that real thing,
the outline of its body, of its body shape
is what it uses, it doesn't require
the the color of the wool
on the mammoth to be a part
of the sign, it doesn't
require the color of the tusks.
It doesn't require any other facts
about the mammoth to be involved
in order to become an icon of the mammoth,
because it picks out one
qualitative resemblance
and associates that with the whole thing.
The next more complex kind of sign,
and it rises in complexity
in part because animals
come along whose central nervous systems
enable them to construct
this greater complexity,
especially in their capacities
for learning and memory,
is what Peirce called the index.
And this is a sign that
strikes up a pointing
and indicating relation with its object,
a causal relation or just a relationship
of proximity in some cases.
The most famous index of all
is smoke as an index of fire.
How does an index come about
in the cognizance of an animal?
Well it has to depend first of
all on some earlier learning
that smoke and fire were associated,
so it is going to depend
already on some kind
of learning capacity, fairly
complicated learning capacity,
some kind of well-developed memory,
not just a transient working memory,
but some kind of episodic memory
that can remember episodes from
early in the animal's life.
But once an animal has this,
it can then strike up a relationship
between a present experience,
where there's smoke only,
no fire that has been
perceived yet, and fire,
and an earlier experience
that was a complete experience
of smoke experienced with fire.
It can put these two things together,
but notice that in putting
these two things together,
it has constructed a not
only an indexical sign,
but it has also depended on iconicity.
It has depended on the way icons work,
because the present-day
incomplete experience
is made complete by making it an icon
of an earlier remembered
experience, right?
There's a qualitative
likeness of these two things,
an index, smoke as
referring to meaning fire.
The most complex kind of symbol,
the most complex kind of sign
for Peirce was the symbol.
This is a kind of sign
that in the world today,
to all our evidence, there are
no animals that make symbols
except for Homo sapiens.
In an earlier world there may
have been some other hominins
that made symbols, Neanderthal,
Homo neanderthalensis,
the Neanderthals are the
best candidate for that.
There was a very vexed
question as to whether
they were symbolic creatures or not.
A symbol is a sign that relies
on a systematic relationship
in a group of symbols in
order, that is somehow governed
by rules, by conventions,
in order to to come
to its signifying function.
It doesn't signify except
once it becomes a part
of some sort of organized system of signs.
Now the most pervasive
and most foundational
and most important kind of symbolism
that modern humans all
practice is language,
and it is a hugely
developed and interesting
kind of symbolism, but
the words in a language,
the words in a language
point to one another.
They point to one another
in all kinds of ways.
Adverbs point to verbs,
verbs point to nouns,
pronouns point to nouns
or they might point
to whole groups of other words.
They can point in all
kinds of interesting ways,
all kinds of words are busy
pointing to other words.
This, by the way, this pointing,
reminds us of the index
and we are going to find that
the symbol, just as the index,
was based on the icon for its structure.
The symbol is based on the
index for its structure.
So first of all we have
indexical relationships,
pointing relationships,
among all the signs,
all the signs in a system of signs
that will become symbols.
But by virtue of this
pointing relationship,
these indexical relationships,
the whole system, then, comes to be able
to point beyond itself,
for example to the world,
as language can point to the world.
So we've got two kinds, two
orders, of indexicality here,
the indexicality that
governs the the relationships
within the system, the
indexicality that then enables
that governed system,
that rule-bound system,
to point beyond itself
to the world at large.
Here we reach reach the apex
of the complexity of signs
and perhaps we will step back
and just have a quick review.
We start from a foundation of information.
Think of those messenger RNA
molecules and DNA molecules.
Semiosis grows out of a
broader realm of information.
When in fact central
nervous systems come along
that are complex enough
to start performing
some of the functions that
i was just describing.
Sorry, wrong direction.
Culture, then, is a semiotic
enterprise through and through.
It is about signs and their aboutness.
It uses, it takes as its stuff
signs and their aboutness.
And finally, in the most
complex kinds of signs,
the symbol, for example,
we see another possibility
within culture, that is to
say, complex cultural systems,
systemic culture of one sort or another,
and we see also then,
to just review again,
information is about
operative correspondence,
evolved operative correspondence.
Semiosis is about aboutness
and that's where meaning comes into this.
Culture is about learning
and transmission,
and then we finally get to
the most complex kind of
cultures, systematic cultures.
So let's now turn to, am
I still going backwards,
I don't know, there,
there I'm going forward.
Let's now turn to some
Paleolithic cultural systems
and think about how they are
semiotic and how they work.
Here's an Acheulean hand-axe
and Acheulean biface,
this one from about 700,000 years ago.
It is a thing of beauty
to those of us who,
by the way, those of us
who tried to make one,
boy is it hard,
(audience chuckles)
and this is 700,000 years ago,
I don't even come close to Neanderthals,
but in any case, this technology,
in order to make such a such a biface,
by the way, this technology
was already emerged
about 1 3/4 million years ago.
Homo sapiens emerged between
300 and 200,000 years ago.
This is a hugely ancient technology
practiced by many different
hominin species, right?
It goes way way back.
In order to make one of these,
you take a cobble, you take a core,
and you take a hammer stone,
and you start chipping away at the cobble.
When you chip away at the cobble,
as anybody who has tried
this immediately learns,
when you, you cannot take a cobble
and say I know how an Acheulean hand-axe
is going to come out of this.
All you can do is chip away at the cobble,
and a flake is chipped off
and that flaking of the chip
then forms an index pointing
you to the next gesture
and that forms an index
pointing you to the next gesture
and an index pointing
you to the next gesture.
At every moment, you are
concatenating signs, indexes,
from one gesture to
the next that help you,
finally, if you you're pretty good at it,
get to something as
beautifully symmetrical
as as this hand-axe is.
This is, then, a pretty
complex array of indexes
that enables this cultural
system to be passed along
and to be taught and transmitted
from generation to generation,
but notice that it's just a
kind of a willy-nilly sequence
of indexes, it is not
a sequence of indexes
that is somehow prearranged,
that is somehow hierarchical,
that is organized in more
than a very very rudimentary manner.
If we look at a later stone technology,
Levallois point making, this
now is the stone technology
that came into existence,
the debates raged,
somewhere between 300 and
400,000 years ago maybe,
somewhere on that time scale at any rate.
It has been studied to a fare-the-well
within association with Neanderthals.
It's also been studied a
lot recently in association
with our forebears in Africa,
Neanderthals of course in Europe,
and here's how it works.
You take the cobble now and from 1 to 2,
what you're doing is
you're taking a cobble
and you're chipping off, flicking flakes
in a rather systematic way
around the edge of the cobble, right?
Once you do that, you're
in, you're prepared now,
but because you've
formed sharp edges there,
you are prepared to begin
to form a convex surface
on the top of the cobble by, in number 3,
chipping off, flaking off bits
on the top of the cobble now
and in number 4 that process is completed.
And if you do this right,
in number 5 you may need
one or more other strokes, kinds
of kinds of hammer strokes.
You may need to lop off one end of it,
depending upon the shape
of the cobble and so on,
but if you've done this
right, one strike here,
represented by the arrow in number 5,
will break off a finished point,
or at least a point that only needs
a slight retouching, right?
Now think about this as a
system, a system of indexes.
First of all, it is systematic in a way
that the Acheulean biface indexes
were not at all systematic.
This is not a willy-nilly
array of indexes,
one following after another
in an unpredictable fashion.
It is a set of hierarchized
different kinds of indexes
in regard to the core
that you started with
that have to be arranged in just this way
or you will not get to the final product.
The point will not will not come off,
it as those of us who have tried
to do this Levallois technology
learned very quickly.
It is very very hard to get this right,
but it's quite a sophisticated technology.
The fact that all of
these indexes are arranged
in this hierarchized set of
different kinds of indexes
that have to be ordered just so
in order to get the final
product is why I think of this
not just as an indexical system,
but as a hyper-indexical system.
Something has happened here
in the ordering of indexes
that is decisively
different from what happened
in the Acheulean hand-axe.
Okay what we have now, by
this time is, is hominins,
several species of hominins,
we keep discovering
more and more probably,
but, and just one last week
with Homo luzonensis
that you may have noticed
in the papers, but at this
point in the evolution
of hominins, we've got a
lot of complex semiosis
that is going on that is being transmitted
from generation to
generation in the culture.
We've got cultural systems
of some complexity.
What is the impact of these
cultural systems, then,
on the niche construction,
on our second algorithm,
on that cultural niche construction
we were talking about before?
Well here's a diagram
that adds now something
down at the bottom that
tries to show this.
What happens with these cultural systems
is that even though they are generated
by the overall cycle, the feedback cycle,
of niche construction in cultural animals,
even though they are
generated from that cycle,
they come to have a wholistic
quality, first of all,
because they have to be passed on,
think of the Levallois technology,
it must be passed on as a
whole or it doesn't work.
Because of this wholistic transmission,
their integrated nature as a
system comes to be more marked
in the cultures that practice them.
They have an autonomy
from the other aspects
of the cultural practices of the culture.
They have a robustness of
systematic integration,
perhaps, as well.
All of these things form what
I call cultural epicycles.
They form cultural forces,
technologies in this case,
cultural forces that that
that kind of come to stand
outside of the overall feedback
loop of niche construction.
Because they are so autonomous
in their integrated wholism,
they come to stand outside
of that feedback loop
and they come then to be able
to feed forward into the loop
and bias it and redirect it
and change its direction, finally, right?
A simple example of this
would be the control of fire.
One need only think for a minute to think
that's a technology, it's a
pretty complex technology,
probably mastered between
700,000 and a million years ago
by hominins, though the dating
is again another vexed problem,
but nonetheless think
of the control of fire
and think of what that would do
once there was a
systematic control of fire,
think what it would do
in terms of redirecting
the niche construction, right?
All right, cultural epicycles,
redirecting cultural niche construction.
Let's look at such an epicycle,
the bead-making epicycle.
Bead making is hugely
dispersed in hominin cultures,
probably only in Homo sapiens culture,
but maybe also in Neanderthal cultures,
in any case in sapient culture,
in our own ancestors' cultures,
and related sapient groups,
it goes back at least
100,000 years, probably
more like 130,000 years,
what archeologists mean by bead making
is to take any small object, a seashell,
a fragment of an ostrich egg
shell in another instance,
a tooth of an animal that has been hunted,
a piece of mineral, a piece of amber,
take any small object and
drill it through or pierce it
so as to be hung, so as
to be hung on a strap,
an anklet, a bracelet, a necklace,
so as to be hung on hair, so
as to be hung on clothing.
Bead making, why, the
mystery about bead making is
why does it pop up
everywhere Homo sapiens goes?
In in vastly different
geographical arenas,
vastly different niches,
bead making pops up.
What is making this epicycle,
what is the force that makes
this epicycle take shape?
For me it has to do
precisely with the complexity
of semiotic cognition.
What you've got now is early humans
who are who are working with indexes
in pretty complicated ways.
We see that already in the
Levallois point making,
but you've also, that complicated semiosis
must also be reflected in
the growing complications
of the social structures
of these groups themselves.
What is probably coming
on board are new registers
of kinship relations, new
registers of social status
and social power, right?
But as these things come on board,
as the complexity of the society grows,
what is also manifesting itself
are invisible realms of
culture, so to speak.
These are not realms that
are necessarily smacking you
in the face, you cannot
tell that somebody is a kin,
and especially a distant kin,
simply by looking at them,
simply by encountering them.
This is now something that
needs, that has become invisible
in the practice of culture itself
and needs then to be made visible.
What could be more more easily understood
than that these cultures
would, all of them,
one after another, use their
sophisticated technologies
so as to construct markers
by which social difference
could be registered.
Now these were no doubt,
these beads were no doubt
not the only social markers.
They scarification of the
flesh, body painting, tattooing,
there may have been many, clothing,
the kinds of clothing that was worn,
it's just that meat making
is the one that was made
with materials that have
endured down to our time
and can be studied by archeologists.
But it shows us, it seems
to me, the way in which
a cultural epicycle can become necessary
in the growing complexity of
the cultural niche construction
of a group of humans.
It shows us something else, too.
It shows us, because if
we take a group, say,
this is a group that has been studied
or at least an instance
that has been studied,
if we take humans 100,000
years ago in Blombos Cave
on the southern edge of South Africa,
they've been harvesting
shellfish for their food
for a long long time now, for
tens of thousands of years
maybe they've been harvesting shellfish.
When they come to be a bead-making culture
using the seashells as their beads,
suddenly a new affordance
from the, a new resource
in the niche has been
invented, so to speak,
by their cultural practice, right?
Seashells are no longer trash
to be thrown on the mitten.
Seashells now have the capacity
to become signs of social complexity.
So what happens in this
epicyclic niche construction
is not only the the redirecting
of the cycle of niche construction
okay in all kinds of possible directions,
but in the course of that redirecting,
the uncovering of new resources,
perhaps the meeting up
against of new constraints
in the environment, all
kinds of things can happen
in terms of the
affordances and constraints
of the environment.
Here's another kind of, this
is a whole class of epicycle,
of cultural epicycles, as far
as I see, and that is ritual.
So what is a ritual?
Well, first of all, it is behavior
that has been systematized,
it's repeatable behavior.
It's distinct by its
systematic organization
from everyday activities that
don't somehow count as ritual.
In all of these features,
it begins to look
like the wholistic systems
of cultural epicycles,
and, like epicycles, it might reshape
the affordances and constraints,
even by using the materials as a part
of its distinct cultural system.
It might it might reshape the
affordances and constraints
of the environment in the
way that I was just saying.
The autonomy and robustness of the system
might be very much marked by
the systematized repeatable
nature of it, but there's
one new ingredient
that we haven't introduced yet
that is absolutely basic to ritual,
and that is that there's
a double systematization
at stake here.
On the one hand, there are
the elements of the ritual
that are systematized in
relationship to one another,
but on the other hand the
relationship between the ritual
and the broader culture
is systematized, as well.
You do not have a funerary
ritual unless somebody has died.
You don't have a puberty
ritual unless somebody
is passing through puberty.
So that double systematization
is, it seems to me,
crucial in a definition of ritual
and in trying to understand
the origins of ritual.
And it suggests that those origins
are very very ancient origins, in fact.
It suggests to me that
what we need in a culture
for it to practice ritual
is hyper-indexicality.
It is not yet symbolism.
You don't have to have language
in order to practice ritual,
and I think we can see
what you do have to have
is a performed system of indexes.
We've seen perform systems
of indexes, after all,
in Levallois technology.
What you have to have also
is the indexical relation
of that system to the broader culture,
the hyper-indexical doubleness
I was talking about.
All of this brings you to
the verge of symbolism,
but it doesn't necessarily
require symbolism.
You don't need language for ritual.
This is an idea that is rather foreign
to many anthropologists when
they think about ritual,
but it seems to me that we can look back
deep in our deep history and see creatures
who were not entirely
like us in many many ways
and yet had already, had begun
to form rudimentary ritual
structures in their societies,
and one of the ways they were not like us
was they did not yet have modern language.
They had proto languages
of indexical sorts,
complex no doubt in their
communicative capacities,
but nothing like the full
grammar syntax and lexicon
that makes language the symbolic
medium par excellence that it is.
Here's an instance of that
rather lurid picture of.
This is a representation of a site,
Boxgrove in southern England,
that has been excavated and
excavated and excavated.
It was a stunning site when it was found.
What was found on this site was evidence
of hominin hunting, apparently,
and also butchering,
then, of a rhinoceros, of several horses,
a whole system, a cultural system.
There was a waterhole, you
can see that in the picture.
I love this kind of picture, by the way,
this kind of peaceable
kingdom, right, with a twist.
All these animals kind
of wandering around,
kind of, you know, happily
sort of looking at them.
But, nonetheless, whatever
is not necessarily
what Boxgrove would have
looked like 500,000 years ago.
Some of these things are what
this would have looked like
at the moment of
butchering this rhinoceros.
Number one, we know that this
person making stone tools,
stone tools were made on the site
in order to butcher the rhinoceros.
We know where the stones came from.
They came from the limestone
cliffs at the back.
We even have places
where cobbles were picked
off the limestone cliffs
and tested right there
and deemed not worthy of being carried
over to the to the rhinoceros.
That too has been analyzed
by these archeologists.
This site has just revealed a
treasure trove of information.
We can imagine, then, the complexity of
and the fraught complexity of this scene,
which is pictured here, as well.
You've got some of the humans
that need to be warding off
the hyenas and the scavengers
that are going to be surrounding them.
You've got others that are
making the stone tools.
Some of the food would be
consumed immediately on the scene.
Some of the suit food
would be lugged away,
probably to be cooked.
A lot of complexity to this, right?
It is not necessarily a ritual scene,
and yet we are in a
hyper-indexical situation
that could even easily
give rise to ritual.
And we are 500,000 years ago.
200,000 years and more
before Homo sapiens emerged,
150,000 thousand years or so
before Neanderthals emerged.
This would have been Homo
heidelbergensis in all likelihood,
usually taken to be the common ancestor
of both Homo sapiens and Neanderthals.
Okay, another review.
Again, we look at the pyramid.
The fundamental information
with its correspondence at the bottom.
The semiosis with its aboutness meaning.
The culture with its learning
and teaching transmission.
Complex cultural systems,
epicyclic niche construction
is involved there,
but notice where I've
arrayed the kinds of signs
that we talked about at first.
Culture can subsist perfectly
well with icons and indexes.
I don't think cultural animals
can subsist with icons alone,
but with icons and indexes,
culture can emerge.
For complex systemic
culture, you need at least
the hyper index, as I'm calling it,
or perhaps full-fledged symbolism.
Of course, my view is you do
not need full-fledged symbolism
for this cultural complex idiom to emerge.
Hyper-indexicality is
enough, and indeed my view
is that hyper-indexicality
lasted a long long time
in Homo sapiens' history,
and it was only after
the 100,000 year mark
that something, that that modern language
fully coalesced, it coalesced,
a rather recent
coalescing, in other words.
And now, again, to think again, once more,
about the way in which epicycles
bias niche construction.
Here's one more chart.
You've got a complex
ordered cultural archive,
think of the Levallois
technology that I've shown you
up in the in the right-hand corner.
This brings about hierarchy systems,
wholistic transmission,
robustness, autonomy,
all these things I've
talked about already.
Cultural epicycles with
their feed forward bias
that changes the course
of niche construction.
New affordances and constraints
that then can then be
identified and exploited
in in niche construction.
Feeding back into a niche that is now
going to be constructed in a
new and different way, right?
All of this process, it seems to me,
is a process that, in in our deep history,
began easily by 100,000 years ago,
probably longer than that,
probably a good deal longer than that,
began to open further
domains, so to speak,
of cultural activity for hominins,
not only Homo sapiens but but a wide group
of different kinds of hominins, probably.
And I want to finish by talking then
about some of those new domains.
Some of these reach back beyond,
farther beyond Homo sapiens.
Some of them are sapient, in particular,
but all of them show the encroaching
of this powerful epicyclic
niche construction
that can simply expand out,
expand the possibilities
of the building of the niche.
So here's the first of them,
hyperdeveloped technology.
Well, this might seem obvious, right,
we've talked a lot about technology today.
The notion of hyperdeveloped
technology as a new domain
of niche construction is one
that comes on board pretty early.
Here's an example.
These are a couple of
the Schoningen spears,
wooden javelins that were
unearthed in the 1990s in Germany.
Well over 300,000 years
old by the most recent
and authoritative dating.
This is long long before
Homo sapiens made it
in any persistent way in Europe.
It is right at the beginning
of the of the Neanderthal
history in Europe.
These are very very ancient.
They don't, they may not look to you
like hyperdeveloped technology,
however these javelins, first of all,
they are aerodynamically
wonderful, number one.
Number two, they were carved
out of the hardest wood
at the bottom of a spruce trunk.
This is all being done
with stone tools, right,
this is an extraordinarily
hyperdeveloped technology
to get something like this.
The fact that these wooden
spears were, of course,
wood is not very durable in
terms of archeological spans
of like 300,000 years.
The fact that they were
preserved is a small miracle
in and of itself.
Another hyperdeveloped
technology, the bow and arrow.
The bow and arrow is now
a very very complicated
composite technology.
The arrow itself needs
needs feathers at the end.
It needs it needs a point at
that is hafted onto the shaft
at the forward end.
The bow is another complex composite tool.
The recent notions of
bow and arrow technology
that archeologists have
been putting forward
suggested in Africa, this may go back,
by some estimates, 500,000 years.
That's a pretty large estimate.
Most people sort of settle
well over 100,000 years ago,
somewhere between 100
and 500,000 years ago.
We don't have specimens
of bows and arrows.
All we have are points
that seem to have been used
to make arrows in some cases, right?
The stone points are
the only parts of these
that have survived, but the technology
for making these points
goes back something like
300,000 years or more.
Here's the astonishing
Gabammung rock shelter
in Amhem Land in the the
Northern Territory of Australia
probably between 28 and 48,000 years ago.
I'm not showing it to you
for these amazing amazing
paintings all over the ceiling
of this naturally eroded away
kind of cathedral effect here,
I'm showing it to you because
we need to pay attention
to Australia when we talk about
hyperdeveloped technologies.
The latest evidence, which
just was published last year,
has pretty conclusively settled the date
by which Homo sapiens
made it to Australia.
60 to 65,000 years ago.
This is hugely ancient, first of all,
and second of all, they
have made it to Australia
at a time when, while
there was never a time
when Australia was connected
to the Indonesian islands
by a land bridge, right.
At the periods of greatest glaciation,
when the sea levels were lowest,
there were still something
like 70 kilometers of open sea
to get across.
These people were
seafarers, in some fashion,
and it's utterly astonishing
that they could be.
We have no record, because
we'd have no preserved boats
or anything that looks
like boat technology
from anywhere in the Paleolithic era.
It would be wonderful to
find it, they were using it,
and it might be that Homo luzonensis,
announced just last week,
was also a seafaring creature
from an entirely different
lineage than Homo sapiens,
that, too, there was no
land bridge to Luzon,
the Philippine island
where where those fossils
were discovered, ever, either.
All right, further new domains.
The release from proximity.
This is a great phrase that was introduced
by an archeologist and
a number of years ago.
What it means is the establishment
of the offline imaginary
or the offline imagination in some way.
Think of the capacity of baboons
to interact in complex ways
socially with one another.
It's a very complex sociality
but it's all face to face.
They interact according to
face-to-face transactions.
The notion of, the question of when it is
in our hominin evolution,
when it is that hominins
moved beyond that notion into an imaginary
that could could posit interactions
that might come tomorrow,
could remember interactions
that came yesterday
and work on the basis of those,
could begin to extend the
imagination far beyond the senses.
That's what this release
from proximity is about.
We see it in cave paintings,
the very notion of painting
this fabulous panel
from Grotte Chauvet, the very notion
of painting animals on on a
wall with these iconic patterns
of the sort that we talked about
with the woolly mammoth at the beginning,
when the animals are not
there, the animals are outside,
is a really a release from proximity
of an extraordinary sort in itself.
But much earlier than Grotte Chauvet,
we see something like this
incised piece of ochre
from Blombos Cave in South Africa.
More than 70,000 years ago
was when it was incised.
Incised for what purpose, we don't know,
but incised with some
sort of intent, clearly,
and this was not a haphazard
incision that was done.
This, too, has been studied,
very microscopically,
in fact, that there are a
number of pieces like this.
They've been studied
microscopically to understand
how they came about.
It didn't come about from
somebody chopping meat
on top of on top of a piece of ochre.
It came about because for
some reason this ochre
incised in this way
could have some meaning
beyond its presence as a piece of ochre.
I've already talked about beads.
Here are some of the shell
beads from Blombos Cave,
also more than 70,000 years ago.
This, too, is the notion
of those invisible aspects
of sociality, is another case in point
of the release from proximity.
One of the most famous instances of this,
over 40,000 years old,
from southwestern Germany,
the so-called Lowenmensch,
the lion man of Hohlenstein-Stadel.
This is an extraordinary
carved ivory, mammoth ivory,
about this tall, of a creature
that could never have been seen.
For which one had to have a
dramatic release from proximity
in order to come up with the
notion in the first place.
Half human or humanoid, bipedal, upright,
but with a lion head at the top of it,
or a feline head at the top of it.
So, the release from proximity.
The release from proximity
is working hand-in-hand
with what I've already talked about,
the doubled indexicality of ritual.
This complex doubled
indexicality is bringing you,
as I said before, close to the notion
of a full fledged symbolism.
And here, for my illustration,
well I can't resist
giving this crazy painting from 1883,
Viktor Vasnetsov, Russian
landscape painter,
and painted Russian scenes
and every once in a while,
he indulged himself and
painted a stone-age scene.
It's an extraordinary thing,
almost like that peaceable
kingdom we saw a few slides ago.
The doubled indexicality of ritual,
hyper hyper-indexicality. (chuckles)
What do I mean by hyper
hyper-indexicality?
Well you heard at the beginning
that I'm a musicologist by trade
and so music had to enter
in here at some point.
- [Audience Member] Yes.
- This is a single pipe viewed
from several different vantages.
Again, constructed from
a griffon vulture radius,
a wing bone
of a griffon vulture.
- Ulna.
- You say ulna?
- It's an ulna.
- It's an ulna, goodness, thank you, Rick.
(audience laughing)
Any bird information, he's
the man, he is the man.
Thank you, Rick, it is an ulna.
In any case, this fantastic
pipe over 40,000 years old,
the reason that I call music
hyper hyper-indexicality
is because, though music
in the modern world,
all human music, is absolutely
imbricated and tied in with
and overlaid on and
interweaved with symbolism,
it cannot not be because we
are absolutely inveterate
habitual symbolic creatures
today in the world.
So music is always
involved with symbolic acts
in modern humanity, but the music itself,
in the nature of its construction,
musical systems across the world,
in the nature of their construction
and in the nature of the the
cognitive reception of them
and processing of them can be thought of
not in fact as symbolic at all,
but as the most hyperdeveloped
kind of ordered indexes
that humans have invented,
hence the hyper hyper-indexicality.
Music is is indexical on many
different levels at once,
even what music that we would think of
as simple music is this,
indexical on many different levels
at once, different temporal
levels, different scales
at which things are
pointing to one another
and indicating one another,
indicating things that
might or might not come
with the next gesture in the music,
hyper hyper-indexicality.
Full-fledged symbolism, of course,
the best example of this is language.
Here's a map of language
families across the world.
And finally, emerging cultural difference,
slash, extended niche construction.
Why have I linked these
two things together?
Well perhaps it is clear
from what I've said already,
but the human capacity to
construct cultural difference
had to have emerged in relation
to systematic epicyclic
niche construction.
The systematized epicyclic epicycles
of the niche construction is pointing up
new resources, new possibilities.
It is then tapping into the
the behavioral flexibility
of these cultural
creatures, who then devise,
according to these new resources,
new strategies for niche construction.
But by the same token, as
they construct new niches,
these novel niches are solidifying
the differing cultural practices
by which they were constructed
in the first place, right?
So you've got from somewhere
between 170,000 years ago,
you've got the lineage of humans
that populated the whole world
that is moving back through Africa,
interbreeding with other hominin,
other sapient groups
that are there already,
moving out from Africa and
moving across the whole world
so quickly that that by 65,000 years ago,
they're already in Australia.
You've got all of this happening
on the basis of the
successive construction
of niche after niche after niche
that can only come about through
the the offline imaginary,
the complexities of
epicyclic niche construction
that enables the discovery of
new resources at every moment,
that then reshapes the whole nature
of the niche construction
in that circumstance,
but that also then forms a solidification
of certain kinds, of a practice,
a set of unfolding cultural
differences across the world,
given the niches that
are constructed, right?
And this, one of my favorite maps,
it's out of date now in many ways,
but it shows a very simplified picture
of mitochondrial lineages traced.
Is is the L1 lineage in Africa.
L1 and L2 moved back into Africa.
L1, see, L3, rather, moved out of Africa.
The M path was the path that went
along the southern coast of Asia.
The N path went into Central Asia
and turned back into Europe,
with an R path that is
not even named here,
and so on and so forth, all
the way to successive waves
that made it all the way to the
tip of South America finally
between say 70,000 years ago and,
well the tip of South America,
probably something on the
order of 15,000 years ago.
But, the message here is that
the populating of the world
could only come about by virtue
of the diversified
cultural niche construction
that was made available
by systematized semiosis.
That's it, thank you very much.
(audience clapping)
Thank you, thank you.
- [Priya] That was excellent,
thank you very much.
Questions?
- We do have a microphone that Ty has.
I'll ask you to use it if
you want to ask a question.
Can you pass that down, please?
- [Audience Member]
Well that was wonderful.
- Thank you very much.
- [Audience Member] I'm
sure everyone agrees.
So you take us back 500,000 years
and kind of up to the verge
of modern civilization,
and you have extremely slow development
during most of that time
compared to what we're used to.
- Right, right.
- [Audience Member] And
then in the second half
of the last century, you
begin to see this incredible,
incredible hybridization,
cultural development,
getting faster and faster year by year,
and I wonder if you could
comment on that trajectory.
- Absolutely, absolutely,
yeah it's a great question,
and it is a very real trajectory.
I would say only one
thing about the trajectory
as you've laid it out.
I think the newest archeological evidence
suggests that the
acceleration is happening
almost as much as 100,000 years ago.
It is really taking off.
It is not suggesting that something unique
happened 45,000 years ago in Europe
with the Upper Paleolithic Revolution.
That's deeply out, because
so much African evidence
is coming on board now,
just in the last 25 years,
it is just remaking the whole picture,
and the picture now has
very very complicated,
I would say, I would say the picture now
has human modernity taking
shape by about 70,000 years ago.
In other words, Homo sapiens,
at least this L lineage,
were essentially like us then,
if without all kinds of attainments
that have come since then, but
they were essentially like us
and I'm just waiting for the
moment when musical instruments
30,000 years older than griffon
ulna are found in Africa.
I'm convinced that they were doing,
given the technologies that
are now recorded for them,
that they were doing just
immensely complicated things.
103,000 years ago, Blombos Cave,
they keep digging down and
down and down in this cave
on the southern African coast,
the deeper they get the
older they get, of course,
and 103,000 years ago is
the level to which they came
a number of years ago, about 10 years ago
they got to 103,000-year level,
where they found paint pots, in essence,
abalone shells that had
dried paint mixtures in,
with the stirring sticks
there, too, right.
That's 103,000 years ago,
they're painting their bodies,
they're painting something,
they're doing all kinds of stuff, right,
so now that sort of
extends your trajectory
a little bit farther back.
The question of the
acceleration is of course then
the real kernel of your question,
and it's a very very interesting thing.
I think that burgeoning epicycles
explain the acceleration,
and I've talked about this a lot
in "Culture and the Course
of Human Evolution."
The way in which the the
production of epicycles
could spur not only, it's partly that the,
what it spurs is a quickening accumulation
of cultural archives,
as I tend to call them.
That is to say, of the
sheer amount of material
that has passed along from
generation to generation,
that has something to do, obviously,
with cognitive development
and all kinds of other things, as well,
and this is hugely complicated to get at,
but it seems to me it
also has something to do
with the need in a
deepening cultural archive
to systematize what is transmitted.
The function of those systems,
then, in driving forward
towards new systems and
finally accelerating
the whole process, so there's a kind of,
I wouldn't call it bootstrapping
'cause that's associated with other views
of hominin evolution that
I don't quite agree with.
It's a term of art that is used for them,
but it is like that.
It is as if the very
process of the formation
of these epicycles is one
that is going to accelerate
the accumulation of more cultural material
to form more cultural epicycles.
Something along those lines
is where I'd go with that, yeah, yeah.
- [Audience Member] Okay.
- Hello, Gunter.
- [Gunter] So I'm not sure
I understood you correctly,
but I perceived as if you were suggesting
that cultural differentiation
is a relatively late event
in your hierarchy, and
I'm surprised about this,
because I think, because this
epicycles that you talk about
are in a way arbitrary, like they
are not ecologically necessary,
and since they are arbitrary,
so cultural differentiation
should actually happen
as soon as there are epicycles,
because different epicycles
are likely to arise
in different populations.
As soon as they have epicycles,
then it's cultural differentiation.
Or did I misunderstand you there?
- So I've put I put the
burgeoning of cultural difference
back 70 to 100,000 years, right?
It's not that recent, first of all, right,
but that's the first thing,
so I'm stretching it back a
little bit farther than that,
so the bead-making epicycle
is a good instance of this,
that is to say, and it
is an instance of the way
in which these cultural epicycles
are not in fact arbitrary
but depend on the
affordance and constraint
of a particular environment, right.
There is--
- So it's arbitrary
whether you start using
a particular foods?
- It is, again, if you think
of the bead-making example,
it's not entirely arbitrary.
If there is a pressure from
growing social complexity
to mark the complexity somehow,
certain things are going
to pop up in the cultural,
in the cultural practices of a society
and other things they're
not going to pop up.
Those things that do pop up have to do
with the capabilities of the
humans that are doing them
but they also have to do with
the affordance and constraint
of the environment,
right, so I don't think
arbitrariness is the right word
for the epicycles as a whole,
but I do take your I do take your point.
- [Priya] An opportunity, perhaps, right?
- Yeah, indeed, opportunity
is another word.
I mean these are, this
is catalyzed, you know,
to use a word from your neck of the wood
in molecular biology, right.
This is a catalyzed kind
of cultural development
that is part and parcel
of the ongoing cycle
of niche construction, but
your question still remains
as to, shouldn't difference be popping up
as soon as these things, and I say,
yes it should, yes it is.
So I didn't mean to say
that, what I meant to say
about recent cultural
difference in Homo sapiens
is that it has enabled,
it is part and parcel
of what has enabled the
populating of the whole world.
On a much more limited scale,
humans in northern Germany
are making spruce javelins
because that's what they need,
that's what they got there,
and that that's what their technology
and their cognition will allow them to do,
so that is a kind of cultural difference.
The bead making, the
differences in bead materials,
is a kind of cultural difference
that comes to be fixed
and solidified in cultures.
Yeah, I think that's true, yeah.
- [Audience Member] I was just wondering
since you're taking questions,
is there anything that you have
found difficult to explain?
Something as--
- Almost everything
that I've, almost everything.
Well you know, it's a good question,
but look at this this Homo luzonensis
announced last week, right.
Homo luzonensis is, by the
the preliminary announcement
of this, I mean they've
been studying it for years.
These fossils were found a while ago
and they only now released this.
This is a creature about four feet tall
that managed to get to the island of Luzon
and was active there somewhere
between 70 and 50,000 years ago,
something on that order, right?
It is not Homo sapiens, so
it's a different lineage.
Now a million and 3/4,
1 3/4 million years ago,
there were earlier waves of
hominins coming out of Africa,
Homo erectus was one big group in Africa
that is usually in its Eurasian versions
called Homo ergaster, right,
but, so, you know, there was, by the way,
a second discovery about 20 years ago,
which was the Homo floresiensis,
the so-called Hobbit
of an Indonesian island of Flores, right.
These are unexplained.
We don't understand how the
the Homo ergaster lineages
continued to develop.
We don't understand
what kind of technology
they might have had
across their evolution.
There's very very little
hint that they could have had
seafaring technology, we don't get that.
We don't understand how,
to go back to Homo sapiens,
how they moved as quickly as they did
once they started moving.
It seems unlikely, and
this is partly judging
from climate patterns
and so on and so forth,
when it would have been
easy to get out of Africa
and when not and so on.
It seems unlikely that Homo sapiens
in the final migration out of Africa
that did populate the whole world,
there were earlier ones that didn't last,
into the Levant in places like that,
but in the final push that
populated the whole world,
it seems unlikely that began
much before 70,000 years ago.
But they made it to Australia
as little as 5,000 years later.
This is just astonishing,
how does this happen, right?
And where is the technology
for this to happen,
and yeah, it's one thing after another,
one question after another.
How do you manage to carve a spruce trunk
at the hardest portion
of wood at its base,
and create such a lovely
javelin out of stone tools?
Well clearly you can
do all kinds of things
with stone tools, we know that.
But these are not easy feats, right,
so it's, it is all of it astonishing.
The achievements of these early humans,
not only sapiens but Neanderthals,
the Denisovans, another lineage
that was only discovered
in the 1990s from southern Siberia.
We have, not all of us, but we
have bits of Denisovan genes
in our gene pool.
There was some interbreeding
between sapiens and Denisovans.
There was a good deal of interbreeding
between sapiens and
Neanderthals, we now know.
But the movements of these things,
the movements of these populations,
there were waves and
waves and waves of them
that we don't know about,
that we have only the
slightest glimmerings of
in the technological record.
It's all extraordinary, it's
an extraordinary history.
To me it's just absolutely fascinating,
continues to be fascinating,
and my effort, then,
is to propose a model that
helps us to understand
how some of this mobility,
some of this differentiation,
how all of it could come about
that is not requiring some miracle gene
that makes us linguistic
creatures, for example,
but rather has a different set
of biocultural interdependencies
that is what spells the changes
over several hundred thousand years.
I don't know whether that
helps you very much, but--
- [Audience Member] Yeah and
to get back to the second
question also, since--
- Hold the mic up
further, hold the mic up.
- [Audience Member] What is,
you talk about in this culture
is something that belongs to humans,
by the nature of seniority.
But you know, I remember
watching this feature
on PBS about cuttlefish, which turned out
to be more sophisticated than I thought,
and the behavior, the mating behavior
and everything else, in offering to it
was amazingly human.
So how you do you decide what is cultural?
- Yeah, so it's a very
good very good question.
The first thing to say is that
I didn't restrict culture to humans.
I think whole culture is widespread
through a large group of
animals in the world today.
However, there's a difference
between social organization
and complexity in ants
and social organization
and complexity say in
a group of chimpanzees.
And the difference has everything to do
with the learning of information
that you then transmit
to the next generation.
Ants don't do that, right?
They are genetically
programmed to do certain things
and interact with one
another in certain ways.
I think cuttlefish, which are fascinating,
cuttlefish have, you did
mention cuttlefish, didn't you?
- Yes.
- Yeah, cuttlefish
have as many as 30 to 35
different flashing signs.
I once saw a film, an
amazing film, of somebody
who in a laboratory held an
American flag up in front
of the thing and honest to god,
it flashed red white and blue
and it's just amazing, yeah.
So they had these extraordinary
semiotic capacities
and the chromatophores and
those are hooked up to neurons
in all kinds of complicated ways.
I never want to underplay the complexity
of cephalopods, octopuses are amazing,
squids are amazing,
cuttlefish are amazing.
Yeah, I don't know that
we have any evidence
that octopuses, squid and
cuttlefish are cultural animals
according to the the outlines
that I've been talking about
here, but we do have evidence
that they do very very complicated things.
The latest report I saw was an octopus
using a shell as a tool.
Tool-using octopuses, who'd a thunk,
but it seems, it's
extraordinary, yeah, yeah.
I will say one more thing about this,
in answer to this question, the
one thing I never want to do
in trying to, I don't think
one has to de-emphasize
the complexity of other
animals in order to emphasize
the complexity of humans.
That's simply not a dichotomy
that is useful to me.
Other animals do amazing things.
Ask Rick, he knows, yeah
go, ahead, Francesco.
- [Francesco] Thank you so much.
Beside some technical
question we can discuss
during the party, there are two point.
One point that is important to me.
In this wonderful depiction you gave us,
some of the passages
imply at least two things
that are worthy of mentioning.
First there are passages that serve
or look at different and opposite goals,
for example the passage on
from in hyper-indexicality
to offline is instrumental
both to the construction
of an archive and the
construction of an imagination.
And the second is every
passage implies also losses.
- I didn't hear that, means?
- [Francesco] You lose something.
For example, to go offline,
it's a dramatic moment
in which you lose
contact with the reality.
Reality goes away and you
need to say goodbye to reality
in order to perform a
number of semiotic acts.
And this is a very dramatic moment
in which you are no longer
tuned with the reality,
and you have to refurbish or re-launch
the circle of the entire semiosis
in order to fulfill this lack.
- Yeah it's tremendously
dramatic, Francesco, I agree,
but I don't necessarily agree
that you in fact have to lose
reality in order to get
this expanded imaginary.
So what is happening with
humans 40,000 years ago
painting a mammoth on the cave wall,
there is an exercise of
the offline imagination,
and it's clear that they're
not hunting the mammoth
at that moment when
they're painting it, right,
so maybe that counts as a loss, however,
what they are doing is, I see
it more as an expanded reality
rather than a loss of
touch with reality, right.
What they are doing is
expanding their reality
so that something is brought into the cave
with a presence that it hadn't had
in the cave before, all right, and that,
so I would only disagree
with the question,
with the vocabulary of loss
that is at that moment.
- [Francesco] They killed the animals.
- They?
- They killed the animals.
- Well, sure.
- [Francesco] Yeah, and
the animals disappeared.
(Gary laughs)
So there's this what we call loss,
and of restoration.
- Well when they were painting
these animals on the walls
they hadn't killed them all off, right?
There were plenty of woolly
mammoths outside the cave
when they were painting
these pictures, right?
We know that's that for
a fact, I'm not saying,
you don't have to agree,
it is simply true, right,
so yes, but these were animals
that these humans hunted.
They were animals that
they interacted with
in all the complex ways
that such complex parts
of niche construction would
interact with one another,
to expand the horizon of
that niche construction
so that they are brought into the cave
is very very dramatic, as you say.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely
dramatic and suggests,
well, it suggests, among other things,
it suggests to me the double indexicality
of ritual at work, right,
to suggest something like that, yeah.
- [Priya] So I have a very quick question
before we close, so where
does intentionality fit in?
- Oh it's right at the heart of it, okay.
I mean, by which you mean the
philosophers intentionality,
- Intentionality, yes,
- Not my intent
to do something, yeah, indeed.
Intentionality is, in fact, a
question of aboutness, right.
It is about a mind directed to something.
My notion of semiosis is about minds
that are directed in
that notion of attention
as opposed to intention.
- The intention.
- But it is, it seems to me, attention
that is going to be a
foundation for intentionality.
So intentionality, then, is
a useful philosopher's term,
it's a very important one, obviously,
lots of philosophers talk about it,
but it is one that is fixed
on human states of mind,
and the reason that I don't use the term--
- They got it somewhere.
- Is precisely to
get away from that, yeah, yeah yeah, yeah.
But it is related, yeah, yeah.
- [Priya] So Gary, thanks
so much for your speech.
- Thank you all.
(audience clapping)
Thank you very much, thank you.
Thank you.
(gentle music)